when you're in The Groundlings you
develop like 30 characters in fact the
character that you playing the boss is
really from The Groundlings yeah
the character is kind of like a Martha
Stewart but like a motivational speaker
and also a tremendous businesswoman it's
an amalgamation of like 16 years ago I
had a little Leona Helmsley in my head
yet that's how it's kind of like yeah a
big pushy know-it-all yeah big pushy no
no that's actually good at it it was so
weird I did it for you know four months
in a groundling show literally two years
later I would say something about her
four years later I'm like I think
Michelle's an orphan and Ben was like my
god who who are we talking about
Michelle who I'm like I think mr. I
don't know is a I think she had a really
awful childhood and he's like are you
are you talking about the character from
four years ago I mean and then 60 I mean
this went on for 12 years he's like
before you're a full sociopath is that
how it works
if you create a character you need a
full backstory sometimes it's there in
my head and if I really really love a
character I tend to like kind of
daydream about them I love her like i
weirdly miss her and miss the clothes I
don't Ben she's real to you yeah she's
she's super real to me which Ben is
always like just one more time she's not
real much faster man he's really real in
here